Hello, and welcome to Al Dente Creepypasta,
horror stories cooked to perfection with a
splash of red sauce.
My name is CZ, and I will be your server this
episode.
This episode is brought to you by UltimateHallowenGuide.com
-- Your guide to all things Halloween.
Valentine's Day.
I've always thought we should just get rid
of it and add another Halloween in it’s
stead.
However, we're stuck with it, it's February
and you clicked on this video, so here are
some Valentine's horror stories for you to
sink your teeth into.
Let's dig right in.
Number One -- BLIND DATE
I'd always found the concept of a blind date
to be somewhat of a gamble.
At best, it could lead to a very fun time,
and who knows, maybe even something more.
But you run the risk of a terrible and awkward
hour or more, and you never know what you
might get.
Tara and I exchanged names and phone numbers
online, then decided only to text each other
before the date in order to preserve the blind
aspect of the encounter.
I arrived at the restaurant a few minutes
early to find that she was already there.
We quickly got a table and sat down.
After our initial introductions, one of the
first things she did was suggest that we both
turn off our phones for the remainder of the
date.
While I was surprised at her progressive request,
I quickly agreed and powered down my device.
I had been on all too many bad dates where
the girl had fallen back on looking at her
phone at the first hint of an awkward moment.
I mean, I've been guilty of it too, so I figured
we may as well at least attempt to get to
know each other now that we had taken the
time to arrange a date.
We started with the small talk.
The city, our jobs, the obligatory stuff.
Then she started to ask some weird questions.
Questions like: Have you ever thought about
murdering someone?
I told her, we all have at some point… right?
In a joking manner of course.
She went on about how planning the perfect
murder in her head was kind of a fun hobby
of hers.
When she asked me how I would do it, I explained
that I kind of like the Alfred Hitchcock idea
of stabbing someone with an icicle.
I wasn't really sure what to think when I
heard what she said next.
She told me, if you do it right, you've got
no reason to make the evidence disappear."
Of course, I was curious as to where she was
going with this.
"These detectives always look for a motive,”
she explained.
“So you simply have to have no reason to
be there, no connection to the person, and
of course, no witnesses."
While it would be easy to get away with something
like that, I did have to wonder why would
you want to kill a random person?"
She just said that she finds it kind of exciting.
It's not that I didn't realize this conversation
was weird…
Normally, I wouldn't find myself talking about
such things with a girl...
Nonetheless on the first date.
But, for whatever reason, I didn't really
mind discussing it with her.
I even found it kind of fun.
At the end of the date I picked up the bill.
And she asked if I had any plans for the rest
of the night.
Taking the hint, I invited her back to my
place, and before long, we were off.
Upon arriving home I stepped into the bathroom
to freshen up and brush my teeth, just in
case.
While I was in there, I turned my phone back
on to see if I had missed any messages while
I was out on the date.
Tara was waiting for me out in the living
room, so I tried to be quick.
I noticed just one message on my phone.
It was from Tara.
Thirty minutes ago.
That's odd.
We hadn't even left the restaurant thirty
minutes ago.
Both of our phones were off at the time.
I opened the message.
“Hey.
I'm SO sorry I didn't make it.
Someone slashed my tires.
I tried calling but your phone was dead.
Did you still want to try to meet up?”
As I tried to comprehend what I had just read,
I heard her doing something out in the kitchen.
The sound of a drawer opening or something.
I was about to go out there and find out what
she was doing rummaging through my stuff,
when a wave of realization hit me with a petrifying
force.
“No reason to be there, no connection to
the person, no witnesses.”
I locked the bathroom door, grabbed my phone
and called up the number I had for Tara.
It rang.
Once, twice, three times.
I started sweating bullets as I saw her shadow
appear from the crack under the door.
She had made an effort to make sure all of
her movements were silent, then she just stood
outside the door.
After what seemed like ages, I heard a voice
on the other side of the line.
“Hello?
Hello?”
The woman that picked up the phone was not
the same woman standing outside my bathroom
door.
Not knowing what else to do I hung up the
phone and began to dial 9-1-1.
She must have heard me dialing, because she
then grabbed the door handle and tried to
come into the bathroom.
As soon as she realized it was locked, she
quickly moved away from the door.
I braced myself for her to barge down the
door or something…
That’s when I heard my front door open and
quickly close.
I assumed that she had left, but I didn't
dare leave the safety of the locked bathroom
until the cops had arrived and locked down
the area.
Of course, they found no trace of the woman.
After telling the police my account of what
went on that night, I tried to get them to
take down a description of her appearance,
but I was told that there was no case.
Since I had invited her in, she hadn't actually
broken any law.
As far as I could tell nothing had been stolen.
Besides, without knowing her name, or who
she actually was, it was unlikely they would
have found her anyway.
Eventually, I got in contact with the real
Tara, and told her about what happened.
She was understanding when I said that I no
longer felt comfortable meeting up for a blind
date.
It's been a couple of days now since the incident
and I've had an uneasy feeling since then.
I've barely gotten any sleep.
Sometimes I think I hear the sound of my door
handle wiggling like someone is trying to
get in, but when I get up to check on it,
the sound dissipates.
She knew where I lived now.
What was to stop her from coming back and
finishing the job?
I tried to tell myself that the whole thing
was a cruel prank… that she was trying to
mess with me for her own entertainment, and
that she probably just wanted to scare me
or something…
Until today.
See, since that day, I haven’t really had
much of an appetite.
I finally had the stomach to eat something
again and decided to go to the kitchen and
prepare something for myself…
when I found the kitchen knife put away in
the wrong drawer…
Number 2 -- Heartbreaker
The stereotypical version of Valentine’s
Day has always gotten on my nerves.
For one, the ads never show gay couples and
I tend to get asked out by guys who don’t
believe I’m actually gay.
This year wasn’t different by much.
I had to sit through class, which I spent
texting my girlfriend, Amy, going over our
plans for the night.
Our LGBTQ friends were having a dinner party
and we agreed to go.
As I was getting up to leave after class,
one of the guys walked over to me.
I don't know who he is.
He's one of the quiet guys who sits in the
back.
He handed me a heart-shaped note reading “will
you be mine?”
I sighed, noticing his friend nervously watching
in the back.
Obviously, his friend was asking.
“Sorry, but I have a girlfriend.”
I tried to be nice about it.
He went back to his friend and I could feel
a cold glare following me.
I'm used to guys being rude, so I shrugged
it off.
I went home and got ready for the night.
It felt like something was staring at me from
outside and in the shadows.
The feeling came back on and off throughout
the night.
The party was amazing, lots of laughs and
booze.
Everyone was intoxicated, especially Amy.
As I drove her home, there was a car following
us.
I could feel my hair standing on end.
Every time we passed an intersection, I would
look back to see if it would turn.
It finally turned when we were two blocks
from Amy's.
I helped her inside and she complained constantly
that it was hot in her apartment, so I opened
the window a bit.
Most people would have made out and proceeded
to make love to their partner at this point,
but I have more dignity than that.
I gave her a kiss goodnight and left.
It was strangely quiet on my way home.
The feeling of being followed was finally
gone, replaced by an uneasy feeling in my
gut.
Maybe the alcohol was finally kicking in.
I got back to my dorm and cracked the window
open.
The night air felt good on my warm face and
soothed my upset stomach.
I decided to take a shot of whiskey before
going to bed.
As I laid there, I thought I could hear the
door rattle.
It was probably my imagination, the shot I
took couldn't have hit me that hard.
Then again, that's also probably the alcohol.
I wasn’t sure, but I thought I could see
the shadow of feet from underneath the door.
I could have sworn something hit the window,
but it was probably just the wind.
The morning light hit my eyes and the onset
of a hangover made my head throb.
The slight smell of blood made me groan.
It shouldn't be that time, yet.
I got up just to make sure.
Instead of the expected, the rug felt wet
under my feet and I discovered a heart on
the floor.
There was a knife through it and blood staining
my rug.
My heart was pounding as the metallic smell
flooded my senses.
The breath caught in my throat and my stomach
twisted.
I got up and rushed to the bathroom.
The shock of it all made me sick, literally.
I took a moment to drink some water after
painfully emptying the contents of my stomach,
hoping to ease the sense of dread knotting
it.
I went back, pausing outside my door.
It had been a long time since I last prayed
and right now, I was praying that it was nothing.
Praying that it was a delusion.
I opened the door and it was still there.
I couldn’t stop myself from gagging and
that's when I saw the writing.
The wall had blood smeared on it, reading:
“Now you can be mine...”
The police came and they couldn't find any
evidence of forced entry.
No trace of who did it was left behind.
I found out that the heart belonged to Amy
and it was determined that they entered through
the window.
I'm not sure how anyone could climb 3 stories
from the outside of the building, but now
I never leave the window open at night.
It’s been two years now and I even moved
to a different city because of rumors that
I killed Amy.
A new start was supposed to be a good thing,
until I found a heart-shaped note under my
door reading: “you are mine...”
Number 3 -- Dear Delilah
Feb 8
Dear Delilah,
These February winds are cold, but I think
you will find the winds of change to be much
more comforting.
Over the next week, pay close attention to
my instructions.
If you do not falter I will reveal myself,
and we can spend the final night together,
under the stars.
Tomorrow, I want you to look for my letter
where he sends up smoke signals, but they
aren't signals for help, in fact, he doesn’t
want them to be seen at all.
Sincerely,
Hawkeye
Feb 9
Dear Delilah,
I know you will find this letter before he
does, for you see old habits do die hard.
Every evening between the hours of 10 and
11PM, he steps outside to send up smoke signals.
Every morning between 10 and 11, you step
outside to sweep his cigarette butts off of
the porch.
You've done well to look here.
I know this because old habits do die hard
you see and I too have a habit, a habit of
watching you.
He may need to fill himself with poison in
order to go on, but I know you have no need
for poison in your life.
Your next letter will be waiting for you in
the post office, but only if you demonstrate
that you are willing to kick old habits by
skipping the day of the hour of habits.
I'll be watching.
Sincerely,
Hawkeye
Feb 11
Dear Delilah,
If you are reading this, you have impressed
me with your discipline.
The day of the hour of habits has passed,
and he has not even taken the time to recognise
its significance.
Perhaps it's time for you to test his discipline.
Inside this envelope, you will find a thin
but powerful magnet.
If you want to test his discipline, glue this
magnet to the edge of your door before your
consciousness falls victim to the late hours.
If he lacks discipline amid your innocent
slumber the magnet should slam the door shut
behind him during his moonlit betrayal.
For your own safety, do not follow, but instead,
take note of the time.
This will correspond to the address of my
next letter.
You need not leave this street, but only drive
West in order to find it.
As always, I will be watching...
Sincerely,
Hawkeye
Feb 12
Dear Delilah,
You've done well to make it this far.
I understand the difficulty he has put you
through, but you have nearly reached the final
night, upon which I will reveal myself to
you...
Under the stars.
To this point I have had you on the lookout
for my incoming letters, but now I do ask
you to do that which he has not and examine
the letters going out.
You may be surprised to find him engaging
with a less advanced form of communication,
however maybe when I ask you to track a physical
envelope to its destination, you'll understand
why a simple text message or email wouldn't
mask his efforts quite like a good old fashioned
piece of mail.
Inside this envelope, you'll find a microscopic
GPS tracking device.
The rest is up to you.
I'll be watching...
Sincerely,
Hawkeye
Feb 13
Dear Delilah,
I must say, I am quite impressed with your
resourcefulness.
Even I may have never thought of sticking
the tracker on the bottom side of the last
postage stamp in the house.
You've worked hard to find this destination,
and your cleverness will not go in vain.
Old habits do die hard, you see.
He is here, right now as you read this.
But you need not worry, as he is passed out.
As is she.
I've made sure of it.
I've been watching.
But before I can reveal myself to you, I have
but one final request.
Consider the form factor of a cigarette.
The inside is filled with disgusting, disposable
poison.
It's wrapped tightly in a thin sheet of paper,
then ignited and burned all the way through.
In fact, a small cigarette is not much different
than a large cigarette.
Both are filled with disgusting, disposable
poison.
Anything can be used to wrap a large cigarette.
Bedsheets.
Blankets.
Pillowcases.
To be quite honest, it doesn't really matter.
But what does matter, is that both large and
small cigarettes are burned.
All the way through.
I'm sure you've already found the contents
of this envelope.
This will be my final letter.
Place all of my letters inside the large cigarette
before burning it through.
I think you will find the winds of change
to be comforting.
Tomorrow night, I will meet you at the grave
site and reveal myself to you.
Then we can spend the night together.
Under the stars.
Sincerely,
Hawkeye
Thanks for listening to Al Dente Creepypasta.
Your total comes out to $2.14, but if you
like this video right now, I’ll waive that
fee and give you everything you just listened
to absolutely free.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every other week, ring that death-bell
for notifications; I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming, we both survive.